what Bill Gross the saying needs to
happen is there you need to get more
than two hundred dollars to pasco for
the economy to expand and that low
interest rate policies are having the
reverse effect instead of increasing the
money supply they're leading people to
put money in their mattresses and just
save so it's hurting pensions it's
hurting insurance companies it's hurting
banks credit isn't growing and for the
economy to grow he says you need private
credit to grow so what is he saying
helicopter money he says helicopter
money and he's also been saying for
months if not years that the Fed needs
to get off zero raise interest rates and
make it give an incentive to people to
save or do more than just save to put
their money to work is really what he's
saying get more than two hundred dollars
when you pass go Yellen s so after lets
her to the may jobs report as well
because of we had a decision by the Fed
coming after that but we had today more
positive data from the IAM
non-manufacturing composite so how will
this factor into their decision or what
are we expecting to see in the minutes
in the minutes I think first of all
looking at the data the data have been
mixed as you just mentioned we had very
encouraging signs from the surveys but
on the other hand growth has growth and
jobs has decelerated maybe it's just the
lag impact from you know slowdown in
growth in the first quarter I think
growth will rebound in the second
quarter and we are seeing signs of that
both survey and hard data telling us
that growth is rebounding but it's not
going to be something super like great
growth actually because you know growth
has been limited by the lack of credit
growth and consumption personal
consumption has growth has been limited
by the lack of credit gross as mr. gross
mentioned so what bad numbers could be
good news for Wall Street right if the
Fed decides to take that data and make
it rain right John I mean that's that's
what gross is pushing for and there
not going to they're certainly not going
to do that if they get good or even just
decent data I don't know what the feds
going to do but yeah there needs to get
to be more money in the system according
to Bill Gross and that money has got to
come from both it could come from fiscal
stimulus like folks in Washington saying
let's do infrastructure investment or
just shower people with money or it
could come for the private sector which
hasn't happened banks haven't been
lending more money and people haven't
been borrowing because they're concerned
about taking on more risk in there you
know they've been deleveraging and the
deleveraging kind of continues can you
know a lot of times people say something
that they think the Fed should do and
something that they think the feds going
to do so we know what Bill Gross wants
the Fed to do does he think they're
listening to him and they're going to
pull the trigger a few years ago Bill
Gross was called by the Fed increasingly
addled he called the Fed increasingly
addled so I don't know how much
attention they're paying to each other I
mean he only manages 1.4 billion dollars
which is you know chicken feet bond
investors the bond yield forecasts are
for you know shrinking yields and the
work Bloomberg work is for like no fed
hike for the next couple of years so it
doesn't look like there's going to be
any rate increase coming from Janet
Yellen John and tell me about that d
globalization concerns that grows talked
about yeah well the brexit vote is an
example of that basically where people
are saying we don't want to have our
local economy dictated by some
internationalist group and we want to
limit in immigration that's something
that's happened in Britain obviously
it's going on in France and there's a
lot of aspects of Donald Trump's
campaign that appeal to similar
instincts or you know feelings among
people concerns that they're being left
behind by globalization